all right here with reaction Fox and
Friends weekend co-host Pete hegh set
Fox News contributor jason Chaffetz
Texas congressman Louie Gohmert we'll
start with you tonight Jason I'm
watching farmer Mike
I mean his comments on race it just put
a you just put a seed in the ground you
cover it with dirt you put water on it a
Mike Wow is that as can you be that
ignorant is it possible to be that
stupid and say Oh farmers don't have
green eyes I actually liked what Devon
Nunez said you know Devon's an actual
farmer I've been to his house I've seen
the farm I've seen how their family
makes a living and I got to tell you
when he compared Mayor Bloomberg to
somebody who thinks that you just buy a
chia pet and pour water on it and things
grow I mean that guy thinks he's going
to be the President of the United States
but he's gonna finally get challenged in
I don't think he can pull it off he is
not up to this John congressman Gohmert
we got yep farmer Mike saying that
murderers and murder victims fit one not
to one mo let's take a description you
Xerox it you pass it out to the cops
they're all male minorities 16 to 25 and
then people say to me so you know you're
arresting kids from marijuana and
they're all minorities he says yeah
that's true all minorities why because
that's where all the crime is and that's
where we put all the cops only am I not
know I live in New York Louie I could
tell you that is an absolute lie yeah
and that is also extremely racist and
it's incredible that he's gotten away
with it as long as he has but you look
at the jealousy and the the bigotry
that's going on in the Democratic
primary I mean you got Bernie he is so
upset with with the billionaire but it's
got to be bank account Envy because he's
only a millionaire there's a socialist
you know I love the Bolshevik Bernie
that you use that's so appropriate but
you know Dostoevsky apparently said the
problem with socialism is not economic
the problem with socialism
atheism because once you move into
socialism it becomes the god and there
is a small little ruling class at the
top and then everybody else but also
Buddha judge it reminded me of the the
story Jesus gave us about the Good
Samaritan remember the Good Samaritan
saw the guy had been beat up he
brutalized so he ran back to the
Sanhedrin and the governor and said you
got to put a tax on everybody else so
that we can go take care of this guy and
we need to take everybody else's health
care away so we can go take care of this
guy in the ditch who died while you know
they went back there trying to get taxes
on everybody that's not what Jesus
talked about obviously being sarcastic
so obviously he's got a lot to learn
about Christianity
apparently he's still on the milk part
hadn't gotten to the real meat yeah all
right let me go to pete hexxit just
imagine this was donald trump saying
these racial comments and you know for
all the feigned outrage over and
everything with donald trump and women
wow i can't repeat the stuff that we now
know about bloomberg that has been
reported even by the washington post i
guess they were forced into it but the
reality is what this is how they really
think
yes exactly if Donald Trump said a
fraction of what Michael Bloomberg said
he'd be pushing grandma off the clip
he'd be well they already call him a
racist but these are outright racist
remarks here's the thing though I think
what we found is a third similarity
between Bloomberg and Trump they're both
from New York
they're both billionaires but here's the
reality they both speak a truth now
Donald Trump's truth was he's saying out
loud what the Forgotten men and women
were whispering for years as they saw
the elites sell us down the river Donald
troops he yelled what we were thinking a
guttural scream of middle America Mike
Bloomberg is speaking the whispering
truth of the elites this is what they
truly think about middle America about
the deplorable ''s
about those the people that work hard
for a living he just made the mistake of
saying it on videotape before he had
national ambitions
changing his party yet again and it
exposes him for who he is it's why
Donald Trump won and it's why Mike
Bloomberg can't win we now knew who he
really is how does this resonate well it
will the Democrats and the media mob
Jason will they go after all of the
things he said about minorities and
women and farmers I mean
I'm shocked if they do yeah I'd be
shocked too I'm not going to count on
the national media to do any of this but
the American people are smart they sniff
this stuff out and you know it wins
elections its authenticity it's a plan
for America and it's the energy Donald
Trump brings all three of those to the
table that's why he destroyed the the
Republican field and won the nomination
and ultimately the presidency despite
all the national media but America is
sniffing out they're starting to figure
out that the hundreds of millions of
dollars the Bloomberg's putting into
this is all a facade to protect lured
Farquhar the person from Shrek who
really isn't who he says he is and
they're gonna go figure this out and
that's why Elizabeth Warren does poorly
that's why Pete you de jedge is now you
know peel back the onion and it's quite
frankly I think how Bernie Sanders does
pretty good because at least you feel
like he's authentic he doesn't hide from
it he is a socialist he's not a Democrat
the mobs gonna ignore this Louis yeah
they will ignore it they'll go after
about as aggressively as they did after
Hillary and and Brennan and clapper and
call me and McCabe for their apparent
crimes which ones not at all quick
they'll worse than ignore it if he
becomes the nominee they will parrot it
they will advance it on his life really
they're gonna say that about
african-americans and farmers Wow
apologize